Senate Republicans are planning a final
vote this week on Brett Kavanaugh a
Supreme Court nomination with the FBI
facing a strict deadline to look at
allegations of sexual misconduct the
bureau now has authority to expand its
questioning of possible witnesses but
it's still under orders to wrap up the
inquiry before the end of this week
President Trump publicly supported his
nominee twice yesterday told a political
rally that Democrats want judges who
quote erase your borders and replace
your values major Garrett is at the
White House with the final push to get
Cavanaugh confirmed major good morning
good morning president Trump yesterday
offered a bit of everything about the
Cavanaugh Supreme Court cliffhanger an
open mind and expanded FBI check and
even notes on Cavanaugh so-called
difficulty with drinking but those
comments were fleeting the central theme
repeated by the president in this White
House over and over the FBI should move
quickly Kavanaugh is a victim and the
Senate should confirm they're trying to
destroy a very fine person at a rally in
Tennessee President Trump defended his
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
earlier he said Cavanaugh accused of
sexual misconduct and heavy drinking was
the one suffering what his family's gone
through the trauma the White House
yesterday authorized the FBI to expand
its background check to include anyone
who might have testimony about one of
three claims of sexual misconduct
Cavanaugh has vehemently denied all
allegations I was surprised at how vocal
II was about the fact that he likes beer
speaking on last week's testimony the
president pointed to Judge Cavanaugh's
comments on drinking sometimes I had too
many beers he's had a little bit of
difficulty I mean he talked about things
that happened when he drank friends and
former classmates have offered
conflicting accounts of his behavior
from the past according to the New York
Times an incident at a bar in the fall
of 1985 reportedly resulted in Kavanagh
and four other men being questioned by
the New Haven Police Department
Cavanaugh was not arrested after a 21
year old man accused him of throwing ice
on him for quote some unknown reason
according to the report Cavanaugh did
not want to
say if he threw ice or not I think the
FBI should do what they have to do to
get to the answer
on Monday the FBI interviewed Cavanaugh
friend and prep school classmate mark
judge Christine Blasi for testified
judge was in the bedroom when Kavanagh
allegedly assaulted her I made eye
contact with mark and thought he might
try to help me but he did not judge has
said through his lawyer that he has no
recollection of the party where Ford
testified the assault occurred the FBI
also questioned Cavanaugh co classmate
Deborah Ramirez who told The New Yorker
late last month Cavanaugh thrusts his
penis in her face while they were both
drunk at a college party Cavanaugh has
vehemently denied that allegation saying
that event never occurred meanwhile the
White House press secretary senator
Sanders has said the entire conversation
about whether Cavanaugh threw ice during
college is a desperate tactic from
Democrats meanwhile Senate Democrats
sent a letter to the FBI and white House
Counsel Don began seeking interviews
with at least 24 potential witnesses
Norah the White House and Senator
McConnell on Capitol Hill called that
yet another delaying tactic it's gonna
be a long week major thank you